Nathan and Ashley are with us in Dallas
Texas hey Nathan and actually how are
you
we're blessed Dave how are you hey how
are you
better than I deserve good to have you
folks thank you for joining us and
you're here to do a debt-free scream how
much have you paid off today we've paid
off $45,000 in nine months why did it go
making what kind of money we started at
113 and we ended at 154
way to go what do you guys would do for
a living um I own a hair salon and I'm a
hair stylist and I'm a firefighter very
cool good very good you guys are working
your butts off so what what kind of debt
is this $45,000 it was normal stuff it
was two cars a credit line and a bank
credit cards medical bills I'm trying to
make all the other stuff a lawn mower
lots of stupid tech yes a lawn mower how
much did you owe on your lawn mower well
when you buy it
$8,000 lawn mower and you're broke you
uh you had no other choice but to
finance it you financing the whole thing
yes lawn mower right here I need to say
but it's a good feeling yeah it's a fine
lawn mower yeah that's grass better now
that it's dead free I love it but what
Dave you would be proud that the lawn
mower that we actually once we get it
paid off we put it to work for us last
summer and I took on some yard mowing
yards so it actually helped correct its
own problem there we go
that's good that's good get that thing
and at least get it into the harness
that's good so tell me your story what
happened nine months ago they caused you
guys to get after this well Dave I uh me
and actually dream like most people do
of adding on their house or bigger
houses and vacations and we have two
boys Mason and Raleigh and doing great
things for them and we always used to
talk about it and our dreams were always
one of these days and not looked up and
one of these days was just getting
further and further into the future and
it was a real scary moment for me a
feeling of impending doom I like to say
and I'd heard new others that had your
book and so I got the Total Money
Makeover and read it and after chapter
one I was hooked once I got that guy in
the mirror under control and it uh it
took me a little bit of a challenge a
little bit of time to get actually to
read it but once she read it she got on
board and we kind of created a monster
me and the boys joked it she's our uh
she's our budget monster she if the rice
and the beans is too expensive she
doesn't allow that so yeah you just get
beans yeah I got it right so actually
how did he get you to read the book what
made you decide okay I am going to read
it after all well he does not give up he
he pestered me until I finally picked it
up and it probably took a month or so
and I just started reading it and it
just set me on fire I had been in
control of all of our money and paying
our bills and I just told him I remember
driving and thinking okay we made this
much money this month but where did it
go never put a pin on it and then when I
read the book it just it woke me up and
Roz that we had just been living
recklessly
how long have you guys been married
it'll be nine years in April have you
ever been debt-free until now during
your marriage are you guys sure when
people hear that you did this I mean you
this is an impressive feat you paid off
$45,000 in nine months and they say how
did you do that what do you tell them I
think that budget is definitely the key
Nathan you wouldn't take that one I
don't know yes yes the budget was always
a big thing for actually she said that
was the biggest thing that helps her my
thing was chapter one of the book once I
got that Joker I was looking at in the
mirror to quit nickel and dime enough to
death at Walmart and you know the fast
food and just the things every day we
weren't we did have an $8,000 lawnmower
but we weren't buying a kind of
extravagant purchases but you know once
you do the written budget and got
yourself under control the rest was easy
and I'll give it up to Ashley she was
kind of our winner on the budget and the
keeping us focus because you know we had
when we know that if she gets the
nickname budget monster we know she's
he hasn't even better nickname for me
but he's called me home with a budget
not seeing it reference back to a
episode yeah that's not the and if you
didn't order just Ryder you said
something wrong his line was no soup for
you and so me and the boys joked that
with Ashley that you know beans were up
to a dollar and a half a bag so it would
be no beans this week no beans for you
today the one thing that I just you know
we when we sat down to do this it felt
like it would take an eternity like our
whole life to get out of it and now that
we look back nine months is such a short
term to change your entire life I mean
it has literally changed our future so I
would do it over again ten times yeah
well you did it fast I mean it really
did the rip the band-aid thing I mean
you guys went after all yeah you know
actually during the course that we
didn't mention the 45 was original debt
as we like to call it but we had things
happen along the course of our journey
that was to the tune of like forty five
hundred bucks five thousand bucks like
windows breaking we had a freezer we had
a refrigerator go out just laugh stuff
that happens every day and usually we
would have put it on a cart or begged
and borrowed and sold stuff to get it
done but we never touched our thousand
dollar emergency fund we were blessed to
be in a position ready to snowball when
that kind of stuff would happen so God
provided there but we were fortunate to
do that and also he helped us out we had
a twenty eight thousand dollar car loan
not included in that that actually got
lemon logged we had a bunch of trouble
with the vehicle and a month or two in
to start in this program we were getting
ready to get it fixed and sell it and
pay off the difference ourselves and we
actually were able to work and get it
lemon load and that was just taken off
the book from the top so wow very that
one bumps our total to a little over
72,000 but Wow very nice to say God paid
that off for us yeah yeah yeah I think
you're gonna be smart we're gonna help
yeah very good
I love it well congratulations you guys
thank you and we just thank you for your
book and all that you do we have to eat
flaps and breathe it for the life I'm
glad I'm glad we gave you a plan that
worked but you're the one that worked it
thank you
you're the heroes way to go guys I'm so
proud of you Nathan and Ashley Dallas
Texas $45,000 paid off in nine months
making 113 to 154 count it down
let's hear a debt free scream way to go
you guys
very very very well done hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show you are not a
victim you're not a victim of big
corporations you're not a victim of Wall
Street you're not a victim of capitalism
you're not a victim of wealth inequality
you're not a victim of racism you're not
a victim